they've come to protect their homes
these Muscovites live in soviet
apartment blocks that could soon be
swept into the dustbin of history
Moscow's mayor wants to pass a law that
could relocate 1.6 million people
including Kerry googan Berger she called
for this meeting on her anti demolition
Facebook group which currently has over
8,000 members why do is that why you
soaps I'm fighting for my property I
decide where and how I live no one gets
to decide for me what I need from you
Lucia Kerry has invited a local
politician from the ruling party to her
neighborhood near the city center to
explain the government's plans the
politician assures people their opinion
will matter but many here worry that the
government only has its eye on the
expensive land under their feet yes we
choose to just never choose to I feel
terrible I don't feel protected at all
this is my only home and I bought it
with my hard-earned money
in Scenario cateura Cupra Nana rabbit
named Eugene Eugene I bought it on a
mortgage from the bank and I just feel
scared now
banku yes just new process Trustin the
law aims to get rid of these five-story
apartment blocks so called Crucial cos
built in the 1950s and 60s out of
prefabricated concrete slabs they were
designed as a quick fix solution to the
housing shortage at the time if the
authors of this law get their way the
large-scale Soviet housing project is
about to become an equally huge
demolition project
Mostafa program enira such a large-scale
project has never been carried out in
any other country it's really a huge
project and if it's successful and I
believe that it will be and that people
will move into new apartments it will
mean a new quality of life for them
nowhere catches Tories needed you
Moscow's mayor said G sub y onion
presented the draft law in February it
was backed by President Vladimir Putin
himself with mayoral and presidential
elections set for next year some
observers say the plan is an attempt to
win votes after all not everyone is as
attached to their apartments in the old
crucial cos as Kerry she says she worked
hard to buy this apartment and has been
here for eight years
there is dill spits Anacostia spits oh
no you see I did up the apartment
especially for me in the style that
makes me feel at home I used to come
home and feel protected but now I'm
afraid that I will lose my fortress yeah
by you so I could have did it Kerry is
fighting for her home to be renovated
rather than knocked down the mayor says
the final lists of buildings destined
for demolition will come out in June for
Kerry that's when the real battle begins
for herself and for others
you